[Music]
welcome to the week in 60 minutes
brought to you by spectator tv i'm
fraser nelson editor of the spectator
in this week's edition we're going to be
discussing boris johnson's big u-turn
taxes are going up to the highest level
in our peacetime history to pay for a
new settlement on social care is this a
master stroke by boris johnson or the
beginning of the end of conservatism i'm
going to be talking to our economics
editor kate andrews and to james forsyth
and katie balls about the politics and
then to tutoring mps to give us a flavor
of a debate andrea lesson and marcus
fish one of the few rebels
then we're going to be looking at 9-1-1
20 years on not just the war on terror
but the debate which led to it why did
people from the far left end up backing
george w bush and what how does the
outcome of the conflict reflect on the
debate at the time we're also going to
be looking at the politics of cartooning
it's a dangerous business now depending
on who you're depicting i'm joined by
nick newman the long-standing cartoonist
for the spectator to talk to us about
the perils of scribbling
but before we get going a special offer
if you haven't tried the spectator
magazine we'd like to invite you to do
that right now a trial subscription for
just 10 pounds and a bottle of pims to
enjoy this late um beginning of autumn
end of summer sunshine just go to
spectator dot co dot uk forward slash tv
offer to claim the booze we've only got
a few bottles left so um rush while
stocks last
and if you enjoy spectator tv it's very
easy and completely free to subscribe
just click the red subscribe button then
click the bell icon to make sure you
never miss an episode
on to our first topic what happens to
conservatism the idea was that the
tories would charge you less from the
other guys boris johnson signed a pledge
one of his six pledges not to raise
taxes read my lips we will not be
raising taxes on income or vat or
national insurance on the contrary what
we are the lifetime of that government
for the lifetime of the of the
parliament that pledge didn't last two
years and he's saying he's raising taxes
to pay for the nhs realistically it's
for a new social care settlement to make
clear but nobody will have to sell their
house in his words to pay for their
social care so what's happening are we
seeing a big shift to big states
conservatism kate andrews joins me now
so kate let's go through the economics
here historically this is quite a big
tax rise isn't it
it is fraser according to the institute
for fiscal studies the tax burden is now
at its highest ever sustained level
let's talk it through
this week the government announced its
plans to fund its efforts to catch up on
the nhs backlog created by covet 19 and
reforms to social care it's going to do
so by raising taxes from april 2022
national insurance is going up by 1.25
percentage points for employees and
employers so in total it's a 2.5
percentage point hike from 2023 it
becomes its own tax a new health and
social care levy said it the same amount
the dividend tax rate is also going up
to by 1.25 percentage points it's
projected this will raise an additional
12 billion pounds for the treasury's
coffers if you combine this with the tax
rise from the march budget which froze
the personal allowance threshold and
announced a corporation tax hike boris
johnson has achieved record levels of
peacetime spending
since these funds are mainly being
sourced through national insurance it's
people in work who will be contributing
most
so how might that affect you well if
you're earning 30 000 pounds a year
you'll be paying roughly an additional
250 pounds a year so we're talking about
hundreds of pounds transferring from the
earner to the tax man
what do you get for it well a promise
has been made to increase nhs capacity
from 110 at its current levels and to
deliver 30 more elective procedures by
2024-25
than were previously available before
the pandemic hit
these clear targets will make it easier
to assess if the government has
delivered on its word but of course
there's no guarantee that it will the
nhs had a problem with waiting lists
long before the pandemic hit as trusts
often failed to reach waiting time
targets keeping people in pain who are
waiting for care
so we wait and see
as for social care the assets of the
middle class are now better protected a
lifetime cap of 86 000 pounds has been
set for what a person will contribute to
the cost of their own social care making
it far less likely that somebody might
have to sell their home to pay for care
the taxpayer instead will pick up the
bill
meanwhile more support will be given to
those who have assets between twenty
three thousand pounds and a hundred
thousand pounds they'll be eligible for
mean tested social care funding for the
first time
now there are many outstanding questions
as to how this money will be allocated
the government is instituting a legally
hypothecated levy meaning that the money
will be ring fenced by law for health
and social care but that's not
irreversible with a big enough vote in
parliament history goes to show that
hypothecated taxes and that's a specific
tax to fund a specific purpose rarely
work they tend to bloat the state but
the government likes to be able to
prioritize funds as it sees fit and
usually finds a way of working around
that
there are also questions about how much
money is actually going to social care
the deal struck is that the nhs gets the
bulk of the cash for the first few years
to address the coveted backlog can
anybody really see a scenario though
where health chiefs are happy to hand it
back or where the politics doesn't morph
into accusations of cutting the nhs
budget
the resolution foundation highlighted
this week that despite the usual
campaign cries healthcare spending is
not insignificant it currently totals 40
of core day-to-day spending and that
doesn't include emergency pandemic
spending
still it's difficult to see this money
being rolled back so already questions
are being asked about where more money
might come from
the government will have this new levy
might they up it
even with the tax burden at a near
70-year high are things only set to
worsen
tough questions for a conservative
government
back to you fraser
kate thanks very much so how is this
debate going down in the conservative
party i'm joined now by andrea litzen
who once stood for leadership of the
conservative party she's backing these
proposals now andrea thanks for coming
on bits first of all can you say a
little bit about why you're confident
but this will in any way fix social care
because as far as what we've been told
so far
it doesn't seem as if social care is
going to be reformed in any way it just
seems that a massive big check has been
written to the nhs with no real sign but
it will get anywhere near social care
well i think millions of people are
going to be totally relieved that the
government is gripping this issue of
social care it's been ducked for so many
decades but um in direct answer to your
question it is going to be a
hypothecated new tax the health and
social care levy and the the government
will be legislating to ensure that money
is going to fix the social care system
in in two areas one is to improve the
domiciliary care and the other is to
improve the care home experience so that
people don't have to lose all of their
assets to pay for their care and the
prime minister said yesterday that this
plan was progressive what did he mean
mean by progressive what way is this
progressive isn't just the poorer
subsidizing the rich
absolutely not no essentially um it's a
1.25
national insurance new national
insurance levy
for those under about nine and a half
thousand they won't pay anything for
those under 21 for apprentices under 25
for veterans from the armed forces
there won't be any national insurance
contributions for them and then for
everybody else it will be progressive so
if you're a basic great taxpayer it'll
amount to about 3 pounds 50 a week if
you're a higher rate taxpayer it'll be
about 17 pounds 50 a week and then if
you are a more wealthy individual the
top 14
will be paying around about 50 percent
of the cost of this levy right but say
for example you're a worker in a care
home on the national living wage of
about i think it's just 9 pounds 80 an
hour i saw some figures from policy and
practice saying with that care home
worker will be paying an extra 100
pounds a year in tax for a fund that
could that is available to millionaires
in what way is that progressive in what
way is that conservative
well i i i don't think that that the
real beneficiaries are going to be as
you say the millionaires versus the poor
who will be paying for it but why not
she often said that you often put a cap
on this you could very easily upset that
people who are millionaires won't
benefit from this they should pay for
their own care but rather than this it
seems to me quite explicitly you're
saying that the object of this is to
relieve people no matter how rich from
the fear of having to sell their own
home now that explicitly means that you
will be giving money to people with
bigger states a quarter of pensioners in
britain i've got assets of a million
pounds or more in household assets and i
think half of the majority of pensioners
gasses of half a million pounds or more
these are households that thanks to the
asset boom are very well off and yet the
tory party is asking minimum wage
workers to come up with a fund that can
be used by them
so it is a fund that will be used by
everybody and and you're absolutely
right it is intending to cap the
contribution of every individual to
their own care but you know as well as i
do fraser that at the very top end
people are not dependent on the social
care system they are they are looking
after themselves as is the case at the
top end where this will really benefit
is those with a modest property perhaps
in the region of 200 000 pounds worth of
equity in their home that will protect
them from having to sell all of their
assets that they want to pass on to
their children or indeed risking that
they end up with nothing left in order
to pay for their own care so where it
really really benefits people is those
who are in that middle income who at the
moment
if you've saved nothing if you have
nothing then you are in effect getting
exactly um the same as somebody who's
saved and done the right thing and who
is absolutely terrified about losing all
of their assets but a really important
point here also to say is that the
social care system is absolutely broken
and it has been for decades successive
governments haven't gripped this issue
and what the conservatives are now
trying to do is to once and for all set
in stone a system that actually will
transform this so that everybody can
benefit from it whether they're elderly
and with modest means whether they are a
younger person who has disabilities or
who needs um specific care for
particular issues that they have
everybody will be able to benefit from
it so it's right that we have a broad
tax base to raise the money right but
what is clear is that nobody will have
to pay more than 86 000 pounds what is
clear is that you won't have to if
you've got a home that's 250 000 pounds
quarter of a million pounds you won't
have to risk that by the way that's a
lot more assets when a lot of people who
be paying this tax will have but what
isn't clear
is that this will anyway transform or
even fix social care there's money there
be evidence of how you're going to do it
really and the institute of fiscal
studies points out that there is every
chance this will be gobbled up by the
nhs the money you say is hypothecated
but it's not hypothetically towards
social care is it bother getting towards
health and social care so it's quite
possible for the nhs simply by the the
the cost inflation the last party who
did this labour party found that half of
the extra money raised by national
insurance was gobbled up by simply pay
inflation within the nhs and other forms
of inflation
so there's no real guarantee but the
care home system which claimed i think a
third of the covered dead were
passed away in care homes a big problem
there we don't really have any idea how
that's going to be fixed
well certainly one there's a couple
points to make there one is that health
and social care are not sort of like two
separate things the point is that people
who are finding themselves taking up
hospital beds could much better in many
cases be looked after at home that was
the case during covert it was the case
before kovid lots of families who write
to their mps the whole time saying i
can't get any help at home for my mom i
don't want her to have to go in a care
home and so on so actually you you need
to sort of in a sense
look at the two in conjunction with each
other what you spend on your social care
system will save the vast vast sums of
hospital beds but in addition to that
the government's going to be bringing
forward legislation to create a cap and
a floor system for social care so that
in effect it becomes inexorable that
money will be brought into the social
care system it won't be able to simply
be absorbed in the nhs to pay for the um
covid backlog but just to be clear you
know this is not something that's going
to go away there are five million people
now waiting for procedures and
operations as a direct result of kovid
that would rise to about 13 million by
the end of this year if we did nothing
so actually to do nothing isn't an
option so yes of course there's a lot to
be worked out in my view i would like to
see an insurance system for for social
care to top it up for people to be able
to insure their own assets and so on but
in the short term we have to do
something to deal with the covered
backlog and to sort out this social care
system that's already broken can you say
a bit more about that insurance system
lots of other countries do you have that
it seems to be an option do you think
there's potential to develop that
yeah i do actually and i was interested
yesterday the prime minister was saying
there'll be a white paper about social
care coming forward i mean i personally
having uh presided at defra over the
establishment of flood re which you
might recall was when we had those
terrible floods and people couldn't get
flood insurance so the government set up
a quasi private sector with government
backing system for flood insurance where
every household of bandy council tax or
hire had 10 pounds a year paid out of
their council tax into a pot that the
government then added to
to enable the private sector to agree to
insure households against floods so that
kind of socializing this system but
bringing in the private sector to
actually be able to um provide some
backing for it i think then you could
have a system where people were paying
insurance premiums and potentially the
older you are the richer you are the
much greater your insurance premium
would be as is the case with private
healthcare so i think a mixture of um
state and private sector would be a good
way to go but i think what the
government's done now is to get a grip
on something that is already broken so i
think it's absolutely essential that we
do that right what the government's done
now though as you say is give a lot of
money to nhs with a huge backlog but
interesting that you're saying that
insurance works for flood insurance
insurance work for floods so why
couldn't insurance work for long-term
social care as it does in other
countries isn't is it could could this
be the trick the government has missed
or do you think there's still a
potential to um to arrive at something
like this before you get into the phase
where the money is transferred from the
nhs and goes towards the care home
sector
so i think that there's two aspects to
this one is we have a system that's
broken right now so we've got this huge
backlog in the nhs and we have a social
care system where people can't get
domiciliary care the the care home the
quality of care homes and the
availability of care homes for people is
simply not there so we have a short-term
problem that we really need to fix and i
do think that biting the bullet and you
know facing up to the fact that it's
breaking a manifesto promise and so on
people will be relieved that the
government's getting a grip on it
however in the longer term i think
people who say well how do we know that
this is going to be sufficient is a very
valid question to ask so yes i would
like to see us looking at a longer term
flood re-style of
national insurance scheme that people
could buy into
andrea thanks very much indeed i'm now
joined by marcus fish who's been one of
the more outspoken rebels against what
the prime minister has announced marcus
how would you describe the reaction
amongst your fellow tories to the fairly
big announcement this week
well i intend to keep my manifesto
pledge
to not increase
these taxes
that are proposed national insurance i
think is the wrong
measure
at the wrong time
and i think it hits the wrong
people to be paying for something
um which we should be thinking of in a
different way and funding a different
way right you've been quite forthright
and that you describe it as a socialist
approach a big mistake it's um you don't
believe it's conservatives can you say a
bit more about that what's
unconservative about this
well what's unconservative is to
reach for tax levers at the first
instance to
to pay for costs which are temporary on
the economy in terms of the nhs recovery
from covid
and i think you know tax and spend is
what people would normally expect from
the other side of the aisle rather than
us but nobody expects a global pandemic
and you'll accept the costs of fixing
the backlog aren't what any tory could
put of a normal gamut surely these are
exceptional and policies for exceptional
times
i think we should make a distinction
between
costs
that are one-off that are not going to
recur because of the pandemic and
costs of the ongoing and recurring
need to help
our burgeoning older population with its
health and social care
needs and i think it's been a bit
disingenuous to for the government to be
mixing the two things up
in the way that they are with this
very broad base and
in my view
it will become irreversible
tax rise lamarcus in the last few days
i've spoken to quite a few tory mps who
say what you say but they're and
disturbed by this some say they're
sickened and appalled at the idea of
increasing the um the tax on somebody in
the minimum wage to subsidize somebody
with a two million pound house
the funny thing is that the tories will
complain about this but they won't vote
against it even you often voted against
it you've abstained so why is it so many
of your colleagues i'm sure you've had
people saying to you marcus i agree with
what you're saying in public but they
themselves will not join you in public
criticism there's a sort of fatalism
about this i'm beginning to wonder if
the tory party is actually far less
opposed to this than a lot of the
backbenchers make out they are
there is very broad
unhappiness about uh what has been
proposed and the way it's been proposed
i think people do think it's it's unfair
broadly
on the working age population
to be taxed in this way and at risk to
their jobs and their employers
who are trying to get back on their feet
after the pandemic i think they think
it's both politically risky and
economically risky
but the reality is that we
need to give the government space to be
able to
come forward with the full proposals and
try to work with them to
get the policies changed and improved
and that's why
i think it's right
not to have voted against the government
at this stage so that we can at least
have a
constructive conversation with them
going forward and try to
fix what i think is a
a misguided policy that's been done more
for sort of pr reasons
than for sound
policy reasons
but boris johnson seems to have
certainly got a warm reaction to this
the opinion poll suggests that voters
certainly older voters seem to think
he's made a sensible decision they
recognize that in the pandemic taxes
need to go up and that a lot of people
want the cure homes fixed i mean when
theresa may came up with the idea of
asking the wealthy to pay for the cost
of their own care the tory's got such a
backlash that you guys lost your
majority so i put it to you that's what
you're proposing just simply isn't
politically sellable now given what the
political power electoral power lies
where it does with older voters because
without older voters the tories would
not be in power so you guys basically
work for them from now on
i don't think that this plan
will actually fix social care i think it
will make it worse
and i think
the people i've talked to in the care
sector and local government are
extremely worried
that in fact this tax rise money will
just be taken by the nhs and it will
disappear they will never give it up
and in the meantime
the industry has to cope with the
changes that the government has
announced
to mean for example that
care providers can't cross-subsidize
their state
funded provision with the private
care care residents
and that means that many of them will be
on economic there'll be less capacity in
the industry in the next two years which
will make it harder to fix the nhs with
the discharge requirements that are
there to
get all the work and the backlog cleared
and i just think this is an absolute
mess of a policy
that hasn't been properly thought
through
and i think it's
basically a bit of a wheeze that someone
has thought up to use what you
mentioned which is the very good will of
the british people to
want to
to help this system which has clearly
been overloaded with lots of demand
because of the pandemic and
force through a tax rise
but call it something else call it a
goodwill payment to the nhs which
people like to say that they want more
healthcare and they'll pay for it and
all the rest of it but face them with a
tax rise that could
interfere with the economic recovery and
let's see if they really want to pay for
that
marcus thanks very much indeed so has
the great tory rebellion simply been
deferred i'm joined now by james forsyth
and katie balls now
james we didn't see much of a rebellion
this week is that because the mps still
think that they might get their way and
the backbenchers still think but they
can put this tax rise back in the box
somehow
realistically i don't i mean there's
virtually no chance of the government
dropping this tax increase they need the
the money that it would generate
and i think i think the bigger reason
why the tory rebellion yesterday was so
limited
was
because there is an acceptance of an
even bigger risk for the tories
electorally uh than raising taxes we'll
be going into the next election with the
nhs waiting list that can have eight
nine ten million now really one of the
big arguments that boris johnson and
sasha javelin have made is that you know
without this extra funding the nhs
waiting list could hit 13 million people
now beating one in four of the
population and that would just make it
so easy for labor to say
you can't trust the tories on the nhs
i think what warrior story mps though
it is two things the first is falling
between two stools that uh did you raise
taxes but uh the nhs doesn't manage to
get on top of the waiting list and so
you are vulnerable both to the charge
that you can't talk stories of the nhs
and you've lost your reputation as as
the low tax party i think the other
concern is um this money is meant to
initially uh fund clearing the nhs
backlog and then go to social care but
it is hard to imagine the nhs giving up
this money you know
if the nhs manages to use this money and
go away from this nhs chiefs will say
look look how much better the health
service is with this extra resource why
would you want to take that away
but if the health service can't clear
the backlog you can see the energy
saying well why are you taking this
extra funding away when we haven't yet
dealt with the problem that was meant to
deal with and that raises what was a lot
of story mps which is you know are you
gonna end up in a situation where uh in
in three years time you have to come
back and raise the health and social
care levy again to produce extra revenue
for social care so i mean i think i
think that you the tory mps are are
pregnant i mean they also there's also
the fact that if you vote against the
government
on on tax and spend that is about as
fundamental rebellion as you can get
but i think i think their worry is will
the policy work will this gamble pay off
yes i think that speaking to tory mps i
think when you're
looking at how you reconcile the very
angry anonymous briefings over the
weekend from mps and members of the
cabinet with the fact there is such a
small rebellion and
little in the way of criticism and boris
johnson first unveiled the plan in the
commons um i think there is a sense that
the plan could not be stopped i think
that boris johnson's power as leader has
been evident this week in the sense that
he is in a very strong position he wants
to do this and i think those who don't
want him to do this don't feel as though
they alone or a few of their colleagues
are going to be able to get in the way
of that
but there's still unease about where
this ends up in a few years time and i
think as james is touching on there
there's a question of will this money
ever go to social care is it actually
just going to get focused on the nhs the
backlog and then prove pretty hard to
take away from the nhs and if so is
boris johnson really going to be able to
say he has
come for a solution to social care or is
he going to come into more pressure and
in that press conference um the day of
the announcement you saw a journalist
pressing the prime minister on whether
he really was a low tax story not so
much evidence at the moment but he said
he was so in that case would he promise
there would be no more tax rises in this
parliament and the most he would do
would offer an emotional commitment
which i think perhaps is worth even less
than his broken manifesto commitment
yeah and i think the next kind of
question is
where does this take
politics uh i think i think kia salmon
has had a difficult week because labour
don't have a clear alternative proposal
and that makes it very easy for boris
johnson to say you don't have a plan so
labor at the moment support the extra
money for the nhs but i haven't said how
they would fund it except they wouldn't
fund it for national insurance and i
thought you i mean one thing that you
and i were talking about um on wednesday
on coffee house shots casey was that you
can always see tory mps in the chamber
seeing
how um
taking the initiative and put
kirsten on the back foot and becoming
kind of more vocally supportive of the
policy for fallback for that kind of
quite cynical
reason but i think this is our question
to see it which is you know if you've
got i mean it shows you how far left
british politics has moved but you've
got a tory government doing essentially
exactly what gordon brown did in 2002
which is to raise national insurance to
put more money into the nhs it does
raise the question of where does kirsten
go and i think i think in some ways he
is haunted by jeremy corbyn if you if
you look at the electorally successful
center-left leaders
joe biden in the us schultz and germany
it looks like he's going to be
successful they have gone um really
quite fast were left on economics you
know they've they've gone gonna be doing
quite magic monetary stuff and i think
the sama feels uh that because of corbyn
and because of labour's uh lack of
reputation for uh fiscal fiscal
responsibility he can't do that but i
think that is leaving him uh without a
plan and making quite vulnerable to
these story attacks
and i think we could see when kirstama
was speaking at prime minister's
questions he had several criticisms of
the plan and he said that despite what
boris jones may say wouldn't actually
stop everyone from potentially losing
their home to care costs and then he
also switched to the unfairness of
national insurance but i think we're
seeing an issue in the sense that it's
hard to know what the
overall narrative is on some of these
labour attacks and i think when boris
johnson could reply by saying well look
what you know members in your shadow
cabinet team have said previously things
that was pretty similar to what's on the
tory office some different and it it did
just uh i think add to this uh sense
sometimes that kyostama is
finding problems in an opportunistic way
rather than perhaps based on his own
principles um but just as i think boris
johnson's uh current position is causing
problems for the left i think it's
causing problems for the tory right not
just in the sense we've had a handful of
rebels but there's lots of tory mps who
are unhappy about this we we know this
from the various briefings they're still
unhappy they've just decided they it's a
not worth them doing much about or you
know they can maybe find a way to live
with it
but i think we are seeing the fact that
there is no one to the right of boris
johnson looks like a viable alternative
you don't have ukip in the way that
david cameron had um i think means that
that side of the party or those with
concerns they don't have so much
leverage if they want to you know say
well this is why you need to listen to
me
and that means that boris johnson is
quite comfortably now managing to take
up this middle space that uh you know
aghast tory commentators are saying
looks like blue labor and but there is
there isn't at the moment that much
making him home to think twice about it
i think one of the other
significant things this week is that the
tory party have have chosen to pay for
this policy um i mean during the summer
months it was remarkable
how many senior tourists were flirting
with the idea of the government just
just borrowing to pay for its spending
commitments for new spending commitments
you know the argument was look interest
rates are still low the markets haven't
taken fright why not just carry on
borrowing to pay for new spending
commitments and i think the fact that
they've chosen to raise taxes is
interesting they have essentially
decided that being the party of fiscal
responsibility
is more important than being the party
of low taxes i also think this decision
to raise taxes has another consequence
which is you know during covid the
juries were spending huge amounts of
money with almost no consequence because
you know it wasn't having to be funded
it was all being simply uh it was all
simply deficit spending and
that meant that it was very easy to
advocate for more spending because you
know it didn't require painful decisions
about what taxes you were going to raise
the fact that they are now
raised taxes to pay for the spending
commitment i think will have an impact
saying it does make it clearer from now
on but if you want to spend more on
on this on education or on health you
are going to have to find a way of
paying for it and that is
going to be raising taxes given that
essentially all the universal
governments kind of easy cuts
were done uh under the coalition and so
there is it is harder to see where you
would find the money in in other
whitehall budgets to pay for big spend
big ticket spending commitments
and then i suppose just finally if we're
talking about why mp has fallen into
line i think it's worth uh
talking about those reshuffle rumors
that have been circling since the
weekend and i think uh opinion was to
fight divided in the weather
genius bluff from number 10 to try and
make
ministers uh feel more inclined to be
supportive and
those ambitious mps looking to join the
payroll
to make them you know keep their powder
dry
we thought the reshuffle might be at the
end of the week it hasn't come to be and
i still think there is a sense that we
could get a reshuffle four years out but
i think it's worth remembering that
boris johnson has been very reluctant in
the past to actually reshape his team
since his first big reshuffle after the
2019 election and that's partly because
it did cause him so many problems in
terms of party management
um but i think it's one to watch the
space
i think katie is right prime minister
has made more enemies than friends in
reshuffles and i think boris johnson has
no desire to add to the number of
potential rebels on any host of issues
on the back benches but i also think
that the fact that hasn't been a
reshuffle for so long it
is beginning to affect government i mean
one of the reasons why uh you've seen so
much sniping between ministers at the
moment is because everyone is
so many ministers are worried about this
this reshuffle and i think in some ways
borderlands needs to bite the bullet and
get on with this because the longer he
delays the more further the speculation
will get and also the higher the
expectations is for this reshuffle the
more people are expecting a kind of
dramatically different cabinet rather
than some small tweaks to his top team
katie and james thanks very much indeed
now this weekend marks the 20th
anniversary of the 9-1-1 attacks and the
extraordinary debates which followed it
we had in christopher hitchens perhaps
one of the most articulate and unlikely
defenders of george w bush's war on
terror his brother and peter hitchens
joins me now he's written for the
magazine this week about the strange
intellectual convergence between the far
left of the 1960s and the
neoconservatives of 20 years ago now
peter you start your article by saying
that and both you and your brother
christopher were very much against the
vietnam war
which one of you two changed your minds
intellectually
i think uh he did more than i did i i
think that
i i continue to view the vietnam war as
an amazing episode of stupidity in which
huge numbers of people died by mistake
uh a futile
enormous exercise of misdirected power
conducted by people who refused to
believe that sheer brute force could not
overcome the force of an idea and i
think that the the failure of the modern
western governments to learn or even
remember that lesson has been very
obvious in recent years particularly
over iraq but in lots of other places
too it continues to be obvious and
there's constant cruising for a bruising
which so many western powers
do particularly ourselves in the united
states that's endlessly looking for new
enemies whether it be libya
or in syria
or in afghanistan rather than accepting
that there are limits to power i think
this is this comes out of a utopianism
right you've made this argument
consistently but but when you look back
20 years ago about the arguments for
basically about what what is the purpose
of western power if west have got these
military then ought it to use the
military to put an end to what your
brother christopher referred to iraq as
a regime was which is a prison above
ground and a mass grave underneath he
was very much in favor of the kurds he
basically thought but the west could use
his liberal force to to nudge m
countries towards more liberal outcome
that would be a huge mortal good now
that didn't work out that way but the
argument what was pretty coherent
wouldn't you say at the time i mean you
might say well i didn't think
practically the military could do this
but if you did think practically the
military could depose a bad regime and
usher in a democracy then it would make
sense if you were a liberal to pursue
liberal interventionism
yes but i don't think anybody who'd been
alive and active during the the vietnam
period
could conceivably think that without
closing a large part of their their mind
and their experience
and simply
ceasing to understand what we had
understood then
the thing that happened to the left was
that many of them were homeless because
they they'd become disenchanted with the
soviet union by 1968
any kind of loyalty towards the soviet
union was pretty rare on the left but on
the other hand there was a very
considerable mistrust of and dislike of
the united states of its military power
of its intelligence agencies and its
influence around the world anyway among
the left and the very curious thing is
how people who had that mistrust in the
1960s
were by the early parts of this century
actually siding with the united states
and viewing it as the new idealistic
power uh the new hope of utopia the news
the new place from which uh hope of
change for the better around the world
might come and that's the thing you use
the word nudge
here's the problem it wasn't a nudge was
it was an enormous uh an
extremely ultra violent use of gigantic
power
which
didn't achieve and in my view
predictably didn't achieve uh what it
was supposed to achieve but there was a
there was a transferred utopianism uh
which then caused a a complete loss of
proportion among people who ought to
know better and it's it's fascinating to
to to look at the course of my late
brother's life in this and there's a
reason why i could speak with some
authority about this because i i argued
with him in public and in private about
this and i i
sensed that something really
extraordinary had happened
when he decided that he he he was going
to take the side of the united states
seek u.s citizenship and become a
partisan of war
after the
after the great massacres in manhattan
and in 2001 september 11th but he did
and i it caused me to think a great deal
and this is this is my conclusion i find
that the left
has found a new a new source of
of utopian hope and that was it and
that's that's he was he was early in
that understanding the dimmer
you see it is basically bringing the
utopianism of the of the earlier trotsky
eyes this idea of the respectability of
society and and seeing that through the
prism of liberal interventionism
well yes quite i mean because trotsky
remembers it was an inspiring figure to
to us on the left when we were when we
were still trotskyist he was not
associated with stalin and therefore
with the gulag not associated with the
nazi soviet pact not associated with the
invasions of
of central european countries to keep
them in line
supposedly still a representative of the
of the ideal pure cause which we
supported along with rosa luxenburg
another untainted figure of the left and
we were searching for something of that
kind my search for it ended in a
decision to believe that
no such uh no such force existed no such
hope
could be pursued that it would always
end in blood but other people still
wanted to have a utopian vision and this
provided it the idea that you could
actually
extirpate horrible regimes on the other
side of the world simply by the use of
force uh was gripping and enthralling
you asked what these what what the power
of of great countries is for my viewers
is largely to defend themselves against
attack and to deter uh evil people from
attacking them rather than going out and
searching for causes to pursue
right and where do you think the energy
is now then if the energy was in
believing that the trotsky knight
project in the 60s moved on to the
neoconservative movement in the last 20
years where does it stand now after the
debacle in afghanistan has it moved on
to other causes or just dissipated i
think i think a lot of the a lot of the
debates about the withdrawal from
afghanistan has been fascinating in its
apparent confusion a lot of people who
you might have thought would be on the
side of president biden attacking him
for pulling out of afghanistan a kind of
yearning for a continued intervention or
indeed
a new intervention a lot of a lot of
fuss being made at the moment about
events in the panchayat valley as if
there might be a resistance in
afghanistan which perhaps we might
support in future i think they've
abandoned this idea that we can
intervene violently
for
for the good of the world in fact
as far as i can tell
that idea still has some mileage in it
in syria where the the west and its its
gulf allies still haven't completely
given up their attempts to overthrow the
assad regime and i have to say i i live
in considerable fear that we will we'll
find some point
which we will pick a quarrel with iran
which might well lead to violence and
even with russia so no i don't think
it's gone away at all i think it's
seeking a new direction but i think the
the direction supposedly provided by
september the 11th turned out to be the
wrong one and i'd
say i think it's fascinating to see that
uh that president biden himself is now
talking about opening up various closed
documents but what always struck me
about september 11 was how many of the
hijackers had come from saudi arabia
and what about your own branded politics
because you say now that basically
countries ought not to interfere with
other countries but doesn't this fairly
quickly become isolationism and
when great when great powers choose not
to help police the rest of the world
then you'd certainly turn a blind eye to
troublemakers and as romsfeld said
weakness can be more provocative than
strength so at the moment with america
turning in on itself i guess you are
advocating presumably that britain keeps
to a minimum all sorts of foreign policy
adventures doesn't that risk
destabilizing the country and
encouraging the forces the liberal
forces which surely somebody if you're a
classic liberal if you're conservative
you basically believe in freedom and
democracy surely you ought to believe
that our country has got a role to play
in encouraging that democracy in other
places and in using and applying our
force in areas where it can help well
i'd like all good things including
charity uh
democracy liberty and and such things
begin at home i think we have very grave
tasks at home in establishing
a better form of governance than we have
now in re-establishing the adversarial
parliament which we used to have which
we've lost and rediscovering the rule of
law uh rebuilding such things as habeas
corpus and the presumption of innocence
which we've chucked aside if you want to
go around the world saying certain
countries are not very well run i think
it's a very good idea to make sure your
own country is well run
first and at the moment we have many
domestic concerns i also i that we
simply are not
and should
stop behaving as if we were a great
power and we have still we're planning
to renew the trident nuclear weapons
system which is a it's a it's a cold war
superpower weapon the cold war is over
we're not a superpower i don't object to
us having some sort of nuclear defense
because we've spent so much on
developing it but the ridiculous size
and scale of it is crippling us and does
no good we we shouldn't overestimate our
power it's all very well saying yes we
should intervene in all kinds of
countries there's several things wrong
with it if you if you then selectively
don't intervene in various tyrannies
which it happens not to suit you to
intervene it doesn't really seem to be
very principled to me to intervene
intervene intervene only against weak
countries but it but even if that was so
the history of these interventions has
been so catastrophic
uh and i think i said one of the ones
which is very little discussed not even
more so is david cameron's ridiculous
intervention in libya which has caused
nothing but death and destruction and
misery and many other things besides
these things are so bad that we should
think very even if you believe in them
uh you should think far more seriously
about uh about undertaking them than we
have done so far i i personally think
it's easier to start from from a
position that it's better not to do them
at all and have to be argued very very
hard into doing it and my own my own my
strong predisposition is against it i
can see that other people could
sometimes say well what about sierra
leone but i think sierra leone is a very
very rare example of this kind of thing
and certainly couldn't be elevated into
a principle and when you set it beside
the damage done by libya it's it doesn't
really justify this policy of reaching
immediately for the jet fighter and the
missile rather than thinking of some
other way of improving the world but
start with yourself if you've got a
country like ours with serious and
growing knife crime the most disastrous
education system in the modern world
and as i say a a non-functioning
democracy
where many of our most precious
possessions in liberty under a great
threat let's sort that out first before
we go and go telling the syrians how to
run their affairs right but are you
saying that iraq right now would be
better if saddam hussein was still in
power that libya right now would be
better if gaddafi had been allowed to
march on benghazi put his the rebels to
the sword and continuing i mean would
the world have been better do you think
well better for whom i i'd you'd have to
ask for the libyans for the iraqis
about the message that was invading
putin knew right now is we'll be testing
the limits of his power in lithuania in
georgia to see if the west is willing to
defend his values if we're not in the
way that you suggest you can certainly
see how the bad guys would get involved
and history teaches us what happens when
those bad guys do get emboldened and in
an expansionary mood
well you're writing a lot of arguments
here how long have we got but the
i think that our attitude towards
towards russia it's frankly ridiculous
and unfactual this is a country which is
withdrawn from hundreds of thousands of
square miles of territory with without a
fight and we treat it as an aggressor in
a ridiculous fashion but as that's
another longer argument
are people better off
or worse off
when i have to say when i visited
baghdad not long after the invasion uh
people were in many material ways worse
often there were other things which
which we
we claim to value
such as the treatment of women which had
gone substantially backwards it's very
hard some uh to work out but i don't
think i think you'd be pretty hard put
to find anybody in libya uh who thought
that the current fiery bloodstained
cauldron which that country has been
reduced to is
is uh is an improvement on what went
before but
what you mustn't do is try to to confuse
my saying that we've made bad mistakes
and done bad things uh with my saying oh
yes i love gaddafi i'm an apologist for
saddam hussein i i don't think it should
the argument should be crammed into that
extremely narrow and
crude oversimplification i have no more
liking for saddam hussein than you do or
anybody else does that's not the point
the point is did we do good or did we do
harm
both to the people there and to
ourselves i think it's pretty clear that
we did harm
peter hitchens thanks very much for
joining us on spectator tv
and now on to our next item nick newman
has been a cartoonist for decades and
over that period of time he's found his
line of work getting increasingly
dangerous a cartoonist who gets on the
wrong side of satire can quite often be
accused of um being addictive being
racist and being well here he is to tell
a story
nick newman thanks for joining us on
spectator tv um a brilliant article
you've written in this week's magazine
about the difficulties of depicting
diversity but
tell me what is so difficult about it so
a cartoonist's job is should be
straightforward enough shouldn't it
uh well you'd have thought so but um
uh one of the the the features of gag
cartooning is a some sort of
exaggeration
and um it's uh
we're often trying to find a a fast way
of um telling you what the story is
about so you're sort of caricaturing
sort of
national stereotypes
and um the the
the problem comes when you're encouraged
um by
editors as you are today
to
make the cartoons more
diverse and
inclusive
and that leads to all kinds of
difficulties for a cartoonist because
you get
charged very quickly with racism if you
uh if you exaggerate too much well sorry
so you say nick that you get people who
say to you nick can you draw us a
cartoon but too many white faces here
can you make it more diverse
those conversations take place
yes but that that uh you know
all the cartoonists have had emails from
um from
various quarters
national newspapers and uh magazines
saying i'm very politely and gently
saying if you can make it more the
cartoon more inclusive that would be
great
um so it's a sort of subtle pressure
really
right uh but you're saying that when you
do then you you need to be very careful
how you draw and for example somebody
even ethnic minority
yes indeed well i mean most cartoons are
having a laugh at somebody's expense
um you're you're sort of
setting somebody up for a fall
and um immediately you you put
a member of the ethnic minority in that
role
um you're running the risk of making
them look stupid um a lot of cartoons
are basically
having
people saying stupid things and if you
put those words in the mouth of somebody
um
uh who uh
um
a b a me character then you
run the risk of punching down as it's
called um rather and
so inevitably the cartoonists tend to
make their their uh subjects
um
pale male and stale
right but would you i mean you've been
drawing cartoons for many years do you
find yourself self-censoring now i mean
let's take ethnicity out of the question
say you're drawing somebody scottish and
say you were drawing me for example if
you wanted to betray me as a sort of a i
don't know ignorant highlander just down
from the glens i mean you'd be richly
entitled to do so but would you think
you'd now be guilty of i don't know
ethnically stereotyping us highlanders
um i think i think anybody ask any
cartoonist how you would draw a scotsman
of any scotsman and you would say a kilt
and sparring um
it it's it's it's all about you
the visual shorthand um you know if i
was if i was doing a serious caricature
of you
and i'm not really a caricaturist but um
it would probably go in a different way
um because um
you know there would be a be a ludicrous
caricature uh rather than this sort of
urbane um metropolitan scotsman who who
we all know um
you know you have to you have to
choose what you do um quite carefully
all right and so where what about
religion i mean we
famously and depicting the prophet
muhammad is enough to to get you well in
the case of charlie hebdo it led to
murder it can it's a pretty incendiary
point i remember 20 years ago mr
spectator having a debate as to whether
he wanted to depict
muhammad or not and i think at the time
boris johnson was editing i think they
got little to try to to draw a pen
picture or something like that i can't
remember but where do you stand on that
what are your
self-imposed guidelines for religious
gags um well obviously um the church of
england is is fair game and we'll give
the church of england the right old
kicking but um
uh it's very dangerous to um to um
caricature islam at all um
uh
famously in in 1925 the the the great
cartoonist david lowe who ended up with
sir david lowe
uh drew a very um
sort of anodyne cartoon
celebrating the england cricketer jack
hobbs who had made 2000 runs by the end
of may or something like that and he did
he drew jack hobbs as a colossus
standing on a pedes pedestal and as sort
of little miniature figures around him
were great figures from history so there
was caesar
um there was napoleon
and there of charlie chaplin and there
amongst them was a caricatured
muhammad
and this cartoon led to riots in
calcutta and david lowe
very much regretted drawing it but even
back then it was it was incendiary and
we sort of i think the british um
press has sort of got you know
appreciates what the what the the that
how offensive it is seemed to be and so
um
we might um attack uh you know the
taliban for what they're doing in
in afghanistan but i don't think we
would
uh go for
islam itself
charlie hebdo is a slightly different
case because
they were just really attacking um
they attack all religion in france and
felt we've got to be fair and attack
islam as well but i don't think
the british press would do that but it's
easier now isn't it for you to get
cancelled because i mean in the diana
days you might have got readers writing
into so many times complaining but now
it just takes somebody to put the
picture on social media and you can
start to sort of a cascade of outrage
quite quickly and it seems to be that
you cartoonists are in the line of fire
almost more acutely than writers
you're absolutely right i mean
it is
and you get terribly you waste a huge
amount of time trying to
uh reply to these people i mean the best
thing to do is not not say anything at
all
um
but it is sort of um
the you know the the frenzy that is
whipped up
um i i got involved in a in a a a
a spat i supported another cartoonist
christian adams
um who drew um again
it was a thing about the um the
irish border
and um
i think he drew a um
a rainbow you know familiar cartoonist
trope with a rainbow and a pot of gold
at the end of the rainbow and boris as a
sort of leprechaun or something like
that with you know chasing the the
chasing the money
um
and a whole load of
irish people came and said this is
really racist and offensive uh
caricaturing um the irish as leprechauns
and i made a
a a very foolish mistake defending
christian said if it if this image is so
offensive to uh people in in ireland why
is it when you go to dublin airport
you can't move for shops selling you
leprechauns and and um and there are
leprechaun museums in dublin and all
that sort of thing well that just you
know you you that opened the floodgates
um and um
you've i quickly learned that never
never get involved in a twitter spat
it's a it's a colossal waste of time
and um uh and also you know you think
these people
are
the voice of thousands where in fact
there there's one person in a
in a garrett in galway who's got nothing
better to do than than um
uh serve up volleys of abuse but um
right but [ __ ] in our increasing we
live in
in our age of digital puritanism do you
ever think that cartoonists or
simply have had their day to satirize as
you do to exaggerate um characteristics
um of people of different races that's
something you simply can't do now i put
it to you and perhaps to run a cartoon
there's more political risk than a lot
of editors so we have spectators run
more cartoons than any other publication
um but i have to say the um it's a risky
business and i can see a time where
people might think well
the risk of getting um of coursing
uproar is too great so maybe the
cartoonist just stopped making gags
well it's it's it's up for editors to
edit and it's that's your decision you
know you you
some some uh magazines have given up on
cartoons um i think that's for financial
reasons rather than for
um risk of of um get
being
cancelled subscriptions i mean my own
experience you know when when cartoons
go into the spectator and you put them
on instagram
they get um
um
you know tens of thousands of of likes
and
so i think and particularly you know
private eye publishes a lot of cartoons
um
we did a cartoon uh private eye cartoon
book a few years ago and it was a
bestseller you know there there's an
awful lot of people who still like
cartoons and and and they're very
instant and very popular medium um but
it's up to editors to decide whether or
not you want to take the risk of going
down the route of of taking on the
you know the you know like the issue of
diversity if if you
if you as an editor felt it this is um
all humbug about um
uh trying to be as inclusive as possible
because
um the actual percentage of of uh bame
people in the in the country is only 14
or whatever it is and so to to make a
cartoon 50 percent inclusive is just
a lie and that's a if that's a decision
you'll have to make and and um
and have to live with um i don't think
cartoonists themselves
are particularly and i think they they
they're they're keen on diversity but
um they're they are we are worried i
think as a group that um by
by editors
wanting us to be diverse it's putting us
in a more
dangerous position
nick newman cartoonist extraordinaire
thank you very much for joining us on
spectator tv and that's it for this week
if you like the show then do consider
subscribing just click the red subscribe
button on youtube click the bell and
you'll be alerted every time we come up
with a new episode of the week in 60
minutes my thanks very much to max
jeffrey our producer and cindy giada new
our broadcast editor freddie gray will
be in the hot seat next week but for now
thanks very much for watching
[Music]
you